[Applaus]
[Musik]
Katar Austragungsort der Fußball-WM
auch ein paar Schweizerinnen und
Schweizer tragen im reichen Wüstenstaat
zum reibungslosen Ablauf des
umstrittenen Turniers bei einige von
ihnen leben schon lange hier
rund eine Flugstunde entfernt Dubai
offener und schillernder als Katar ein
Paradies für fremde wenn man sich an die
Regeln hält
[Musik]
wir begleiten fünf Schweizerinnen und
Schweizer die sich auf das Abenteuer am
Golf eingelassen haben worin liegt der
Reiz was sind die Herausforderungen
ihres Alltags und fühlen Sie sich trotz
der kulturellen Unterschiede heimisch
[Musik]
in Kattas Hauptstadt Doha dreht sich
alles um die Weltmeisterschaft
Coralie die Rüssel ist nach ihrer
Mutterschaftsurlaub zurück im Job sie
arbeitet für das Supreme Committee der
Stelle die für die FIFA vor Ort die WM
organisiert vor der Eröffnung turmt sich
die Arbeit
[Gelächter]
das hier ist mein Büro ich bin im Moment
alleine weil ich wegen der Kinder sehr
früh aufstehe außerdem bin ich jemand
der sehr gerne morgens die Dinge
erledigt
das Coralie ihr Büro zeigt ist eine
absolute Ausnahme in ihrem Job hat sie
täglich mit den Botschaften aus aller
Welt zu tun eine anspruchsvolle Aufgabe
und streng vertraulich
ja das ist super interessant sehr
schwierig weil die Botschaften die haben
doch einen gewissen Anspruch einen
Etikette und Protokoll
es ist nicht immer einfach aber sehr
interessant
[Musik]
nur noch ein halbes Jahr bis zur WM
Coralie hat alle Hände voll zu tun
der tägliche Spagat zwischen ihrem Job
und den Kindern zu Hause macht die Sache
nicht einfacher
unsere Nanny schreibt mir gerade dass
wir keine Windel mehr für meine Tochter
haben
also kaufe ich jetzt Windeln
die Freuden und Leiden eine
arbeitstätigen Mutter
Multitasking eben
der Wiedereinstieg zwei Monate nach der
Geburt ihrer kleinen Tochter fällt ihr
schwer
ich vermisse die Kinder mein Sohn ist im
Kindergarten das geht aber meine Tochter
ist zu Hause bei der Nanny das will ich
natürlich nicht ich wäre lieber zu Hause
aber im Moment habe ich leider keine
Wahl
aber ich hoffe natürlich dass ich am 19
dezember 2022 alles entspannen wird dann
werde ich viel mehr von meinen Kindern
haben aber nein ich habe großen Respekt
vor berufstätigen Müttern das ist
einfach verrückt ich weiß nicht wie die
das machen es ist wirklich wirklich
nicht einfach aber da muss man durch
in Dubai ist Matteo Buffon mit seinen
diversen Start-ups beschäftigt die Stadt
ist ein Eldorado für neue Ideen der
gebürtige Tessiner setzt auf
Nachhaltigkeit in einem Industriegebiet
außerhalb des City lässt er aus alten
Werbebannern neue Umhängetaschen
produzieren
[Musik]
kleine Fabrik besteht seit 2005 die
Arbeiter stammen aus Indien und arbeiten
wie Sie es gewohnt sind zum Teil barfuß
auf dem Boden
auch für Matteo ein
gewöhnungsbedürftiges Bild
Schirm
eine solche Fabrik findet man in der
Schweiz wohl nicht
es ist schon schräg dieser gelb zwischen
Wolkenkratzer Glamour und Gold und nur
wenige Minuten entfernt ein Umfeld wie
dieses hier
statt im Müll landen alte Werbebanner
aus Plastik unter der Nähmaschine und
werden zu Geld Upcycling nennt sich das
ich liebe diese Art Arbeit
als Matteo mir davon erzählt hat war ich
überrascht dass wir so etwas auch bei
uns machen können
wir schaffen aus alten Produkten etwas
Neues
etwas trendiges für die nächste
Generation
mir ist das wichtig ein Unternehmen
aufzubauen das nicht nur sozial oder
ökologisch nachhaltig ist sondern auch
Geld einbringt
Matthäus Kunden sind meist Unternehmen
die gleich mehrere hundert Taschen
kaufen und diese an ihre Kunden
weitergeben sein finanzieller Vorteil
eine Gewinnmarge von rund 35%
und noch schöne ist dass die
umhängegurten dieser Taschen aus
gebrauchten Auto Sicherheitsgurten
hergestellt werden es gibt Ihnen
zusätzlich einen nachhaltigen Touch
etwa 70% aller Fremdarbeiter in Dubai
Arbeiten im Niedriglohnsektor Matteo hat
lange nach einem geeigneten
Geschäftspartner gesucht die Mohammad
seinen Laden führt stimmt für ihn
man sollte das hier nicht negativ
bewerten es ist ein Unternehmen das seit
vielen Jahren produziert dass seine
nutzen schafft Arbeitsplätze und dass
sich sicher an alle staatlichen Regeln
und auch an alle sicherheits- und
zahlungsvorschriften für die Mitarbeiter
hält es ist natürlich anders als das was
wir aus der Schweiz kennen aber das
bedeutet nicht dass es falsch oder nicht
korrekt ist also muss man die Dinge
immer etwas differenzierter betrachten
nicht bloß als das was man hinter meinem
denken sie
in Katar steigt das Fußballfieber 8 neue
Stadien ließ das Emirat errichten und
wurde für die Bedingungen auf den
Baustellen stark kritisiert
die Gewerkschafterin Rita skyavi führt
seit 2018 mit einem internationalen Team
regelmäßig Inspektionen vor Ort durch
fast 6000 Menschen haben an diesem
Stadion mitgearbeitet 500 Subunternehmen
wurden beauftragt
war erfolgreich und wir sind stolz auf
diese Leistung
und wir haben von allen die
mitgearbeitet haben hier ein Foto
angebracht
eine Geste zu Ehren der Arbeiter
vielleicht ein Ergebnis guter
Gewerkschaftsarbeit am Anfang haben wir
ja Schwierigkeiten
mit der Kampagne praktisch nach 2002
und das sind Kataris sehr zurückhaltend
und nachher vom Moment da eigentlich wo
so gewisses Vertrauen hergestellt x und
wo man genau besprochen hat miteinander
machen und das arbeitergat
und man dann im siebent sein in der
Vertrag miteinander unterschrieben hat
mit dem Supreme
vor deiner muss ich sagen ist es
erstaunlich gut
und sie ist immer besser Wort im Sinn
von mir sind immer freie exiden
Rita besucht das bereits fertiggestellte
alciano-stadion eine architektonische
und angesichts der extremen Bedingungen
auch logistischer Höchstleistung
das Wüstenklima war ein wichtiger Punkt
als das gewerkschaftsteam die ersten
Inspektionen auf den Baustellen
durchführte als großes Problem ist Hitz
gesehen und sitzmanagement das hat sich
enorm verbessert er hat euch vorher
verzählt dass gerade dem Stadiums
ist drin kann dann sind ja liebe schwer
sie und dann haben sie liebe Entwickler
aber
bis hoch modernes wo wo
mit Wasser Vollmacht und den kühlt
ganzkörper für mehrere Stunden also da
haben sie neue Sachen neue Techniken
ausprobiert
auch das Stadion selbst wurde mit einem
besonderen Kühlsystem ausgestattet um
die Spieler und die unteren
Zuschauerränge vor der Wüstenhitze zu
schützen
[Musik]
wir vermutete
immer dass das da weiter überwacht
werdet und das Lied wo
gesundheitliche Probleme haben dann
nicht
geschätzte 150 Milliarden Franken
investiert Katar in eine komplett
erneuerte Infrastruktur dazu gehören
neben den Stadien auch Hotels wie das
Waldorf Astoria Luc sale von Chris
Franzen er steht unter enormen Zeitdruck
bis zur WM muss alles fertig sein
durch die WM sind die Zustände auf allen
Baustellen in die Kritik geraten ein
großer Punkt viele Fremdarbeiter müssen
hohe Gebühren an Vermittlungsagenturen
bezahlen
das komplett zeliminieren man muss
einfach schon sicher sein arbeitet wo
die gleichphilosophie Hemd und und sich
verfolgend und einfach ethisch auf der
Mikro Ebene sind wir zahlen der Firma
und das sind also die dürfen nicht
vorgestellt
chris ist Hotelier in dritter Generation
und Druck gewohnt doch die neue Aufgabe
hat es in sich sein Hotel soll zur
Fußball-WM ausgewählte VIP-Gäste
beherbergen
viel Zeit für Experimente bleibt da
nicht
normalerweise
bis dann landet fast jedes Problem auf
seinem Tisch und sei es auch noch so
klein aktuell die neuen
mitarbeiter-shirts XL
it
no no
fit sondern
rund 40 Kilometer südlich geht die
Stadionbesichtigung in die nächste Runde
als Inspektorin achtet Rita nicht nur
auf das Wohl der Bauarbeiter sie erhält
auch Einblicke in die umziehkabinen der
Fußballstars
alle ihre kleine
mindestens 4,5 Milliarden Schweizer
Franken soll Katar insgesamt für den Bau
der neuen Stadien bezahlt haben
einige von ihnen werden nach dem Turnier
verkleinert umfunktioniert oder sogar
wieder demontiert
das war ich auch noch nie auf einem
fußball-rasen in einem richtigen Stadium
lange herrschte in Katar das
cafala-system die Arbeiter mussten ihre
Pässe abgeben und waren dadurch komplett
von ihren Arbeitgebern abhängig
dieses System ist nun offiziell
abgeschafft worden
[Musik]
aus dem Bezug auf der Bau von der Staat
ja ist am Anfang ausoxy dass das
kavallersystem existiert hat die haben
zum Teil sehr höhere
Vermittlungsgebühren und das ist
vielleicht eine von der größten
Errungenschaften dass man jetzt die
elytern
abzahlen mit der Abschaffung
aber es ist noch nicht überall
implementiert aber da auf der Baustelle
von der wm-han
umgesetzt und darum sind wir nicht
gesehen
vor zweieinhalb Jahren ist Andrea
Hirschi mit ihrer Familie nach Dubai
gekommen ihr Coiffeurgeschäft in Bern
für die 41-Jährige von hier aus weiter
aktuell
die Verwandlung von der Power zur
Business-Frau folgt einer festen Routine
[Musik]
und ich habe ja das Geschäft kann
einer der Vorteile der Pandemie
mittlerweile kann man wirklich von
überall auf der Welt aus arbeiten
[Musik]
wann immer es sich einrichten lässt
schaut Andrea daher vor Ort nach dem
Rechten die seltenen Heimatbesuche nutzt
Andreas Mutter Katharina natürlich um
ihre Tochter und Enkelin zumindest kurz
zu Gesicht zu bekommen
[Musik]
ich versuche also auch drei Monate
aber intensiv
in Andreas Abwesenheit führt Conny
Rotzler ihre rechte Hand den Laden
genau
[Musik]
Andrea unterstützt mich halt zu 200%,
wenn irgendwo was
über WhatsApp oder E-Mail oder und sich
und immer sofort und probiert Lösungen
ja
das Geschäft zurückzulassen war schwer
aber die beiden haben es gut auf die
Reihe gekriegt
zurück
ja und er ist dummerweise
und das Zimmer also mit der Conny also
das ist für mich
guten Morgen
regelmäßige Videocalls sind wichtig fürs
Tagesgeschäft doch sie führen Andrea
auch vor Augen was ihr in der Fremde so
sehr fehlt
also das ist sehr schwer
ich vermisse es
ich vermisse es im ladestar die ganze
Zeit aber
so nochmal also es ist schon
nicht einfach
[Musik]
Matteo und seine Frau Meghan sind auf
dem Weg zum Hotspot the farm heute hätte
ihre große Hochzeitsfeier stattfinden
soll statt mit ihren Familien zu feiern
gehen die beiden nun brunchen im
angesagten Bistro von Meghans Freundin
Carmen
großen Respekt habe ist das kamen als
furty on the Thirty zu einer der besten
Köchinnen des Nahen Ostens gewählt
worden ist
und es hat sie verdient sie ist eine
fantastische Frau
Meghan und sie sind wirklich ein enges
Team
Carmen stammt wie Meghan aus Südafrika
und ist zudem Meghans Trauzeugin Thema
heute natürlich die abgesagte
Hochzeitsfeier feeling
Carmen und Meghan haben sich in Dubai
kennengelernt sie verbindet die
gemeinsame Muttersprache afrikans
[Gelächter]
dressed
am Anfang war das für mich schon eine
seltsame und typische Sprache
mittlerweile verstehe ich mehr sie
denken
afrikans ist lustig vor allem die Musik
ich liebe afrikansons
[Gelächter]
anders als Dubai startete Katar erst
Mitte der 1990er Jahre seinen
Modernisierungsprozess für das Emirat
ein Balanceakt zwischen strukturellem
Wachstum und Bewahrung der eigenen
Kultur
[Musik]
ist als zweijährige mit ihrer Mutter aus
der Westschweiz nach Katar gekommen
mittlerweile ist sie selbst Mutter
zweier Kinder
Nanny Alma sorgt für das Mittagessen
ohne ihre Unterstützung wäre es für
Coralie unmöglich die Doppelbelastung zu
bewältigen
danke Alma
sie gehört zur Familie aber sie ist
lieber für sich alleine oft kocht sie
dasselbe für sich aber sie mag es ruhig
und friedlich
nach dem Essen gibt es für den
Zweijährigen Abdul Rahman nichts
Schöneres als den Disney Film Lion King
wann immer möglich setzt sich sein Vater
sei dazu
ich versuche so viel Zeit wie möglich
mit ihnen zu verbringen aber ich muss
arbeiten und habe meine motorradkarriere
doch ich versuche immer Zeit für die
Kinder zu finden vor allem diese zwei
oder drei Stunden nach seinem
Mittagsschlaf wenn er spielt
okay okay okay
multinationale Kindererziehung bei
Coralie und Zeit läuft einiges anders
als in einer traditionellen
katari-familie
wenn eine Frau ein Kind bekommt geht sie
für die ersten 40 Tage normalerweise
zurück ins Haus ihre Eltern
damit ihre Mutter und ihre Schwester
sich in dieser Zeit um sie kümmern
aber hier habe ich das gemacht
ja also das machen wir anders er ist ein
toller Dart ganz sicher dass es keine
Frage
seit September 2018 sind corali und Zeit
offiziell verheiratet doch da Coralie
von den Behörden immer noch als
Europäerin gesehen wird und seit bei der
Militärpolizei arbeitet musste das Paar
um seine Ehe kämpfen
wenn du jemanden heiraten willst der
nicht aus Katar stammt brauchst seine
Bewilligung der Regierung ich habe sie
beantragt sie haben abgelehnt dreimal
die Bevölkerung von Katar ist nicht groß
es gibt nur neun oder zehn Familien die
ursprünglich aus Katar stammen meine
Familie ist eine von ihnen
ich denke sie wollen das Bewahren und
dass sich jemanden aus Katar heirate
es gibt ein arabisches Sprichwort hinter
jeder Verzögerung steckt etwas Gutes
wir wissen genau wenn wir zum Beispiel
streiten geben wir deswegen nicht gleich
auf wir haben für diese Ehe so lange
gekämpft wir wollen einfach dass sie
funktioniert
unsere Beziehung ist stärker geworden
viel stärker in dieser Zeit der
Ungewissheit
kennengelernt haben sie sich an der
Rennstrecke die Begeisterung für
Motorsport auch eine Liebe die beide
teilen
die Frau eines Rennfahrers zu sein
bringt gewisse Vorteile mit sich das
habe ich von meinem Mann zum Geburtstag
bekommen patriotisch wie ich bin
Dubai ist die größte Stadt der
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate von den
rund drei Millionen Einwohnern sind rund
85% Ausländer wie Meghan und Matteo
die beiden haben sich hier kennengelernt
nicht am Strand sondern per App ich
hätte nicht gedacht auf tinder meinen
Ehemann und die Liebe meines Lebens zu
finden aber zum Glück hat es für mich
funktioniert
am Anfang fanden wir es peinlich es
jemandem zu sagen vor allem in
Geschäftskreisen weil es irgendwie
unromantisch schien
später haben wir gemerkt dass es in
Dubai ganz normal ist aber zuerst haben
wir eine Fake Story erzählt
ja wir haben uns eine Geschichte
ausgedacht ich hätte meinen Ausweis
verloren Matteo hätte ihn gefunden und
mich dann auf Facebook kontaktiert aber
es war tinder
jetzt planen die beiden ihre gemeinsame
Zukunft in Dubai
aktuell reden sie über ein größeres Haus
und Nachwuchs
Familienleben in der Wüstenmetropole wie
wird das sein
du weißt das Leben leichter es besteht
schon die Gefahr dass du verwöhnt wirst
genauso ist es mit deinen Kindern sie
wachsen hier ganz anders auf als in der
Schweiz du kannst hier nicht einfach
draußen Fußball spielen auf der anderen
Seite lernen Sie hier viele Kulturen
kennen viele Religionen und Traditionen
oh mein Gott
eine Lebenskrise brachte Matteo nach
Dubai doch der Sprung ins Ungewisse hat
sich als Chance entpuppt
[Musik]
sie ist nicht nur meine Frau sondern
auch mein bester Freund wir haben viel
gemeinsam und ja uns wird niemals
langweilig wirklich nicht
[Musik]
anders als Katar inszeniert sich Dubai
als glitzerndes Touristenparadies fast
17 Millionen Besucher kamen 2019 ins
Land
Andrea holt einen ganz besonderen Gast
vom Flughafen ab ihr jüngerer Bruder
Michael will gemeinsam mit Andreas
Familie seinen Geburtstag feiern
der Flughafen von Dubai ist mit rund 80
Millionen Passagieren jährlich einer der
größten der Welt
sorry hi
I sugar
also Bern ist übersichtlicher
markieren kannst du
Andrea und ihr Bruder haben ein enges
Verhältnis für den Geburtstag hat sie
eine Überraschung vorbereitet
ehrlich
Nationalsportart und ich ziemlich gut
und ich habe überlegt
und ich glaube er wird sich richtig
richtig freuen super
[Gelächter]
Michael ist mit Kollege Jan angereist
die Vorfreude auf ein paar ausgelassene
Tage ist groß
während Dubai eines der sieben
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate ist geht
Katar seinen eigenen Weg
die Gigantomanie des Nachbarn betrachten
viele katari mit Skepsis
andererseits entstehen auch in Doha
viele Orts neue moderne Quartiere wie
the pearl eine künstliche Insel mit zum
Teil exklusiven Luxusimmobilien
früher gab es keine
Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung und man hat
noch Kamele auf der Straße gesehen
das monatliche Durchschnittseinkommen
liegt in Katar bei etwa 4000 Schweizer
Franken mit ihrem doppelten Einkommen
und zeits Preisgeldern ist coralis
Familie bisher gut durchgekommen
[Musik]
möchtest du später auch mit Motorrädern
zu tun haben willst du einmal die erste
katarische Frau sein die internationale
Motorradrennen fährt
Abdul rachman ist Feuer und Flamme für
alles was nach Motoren aussieht
und Zeit freut es natürlich
er ist ein toller Vater manchmal könnt
ihr etwas strenger sein aber er ist viel
weg wenn er dann zu Hause ist möchte
Abdul Rahman nicht gegen sich aufbringen
wenn er Gelegenheit dazu hat macht Zeit
jeden Spaß mit
in Dubai beschert Andrea ihrem Bruder
Michael einen Geburtstag der besonderen
Art
happy birthday
die beiden haben schon als Kinder viel
zusammen unternommen da die Eltern
berufstätig waren lebten Andrea und
Michael zeitweise bei den Großeltern in
einem Zimmer eine gute aber einfache
Kindheit ohne Luxus die sie bis heute
verbindet
durch geburtstag
zum Küchlein gibt es als Geschenk noch
eine Sommerfrisur dazu für Andrea eine
gute Gelegenheit wieder mal zu üben
Ferien
ein bisschen Tratsch eine Seltenheit für
Andrea seit sie in Dubai ist
was die Dankbarkeit und das ist ein
bisschen
baldmöglichst möchte Andrea eine
Freelancer Coiffeur Lizenz für Dubai
beantragen so
auch im schicken hafenquartier Marina
geht es um die Frisur Matteo hat online
einen coiffeur-termin vereinbart für
seine beiden Katzen
der Coiffeur kommt wie hier üblich
direkt nach Hause
120 Schweizer Franken kostet die neue
Frisur für beide Katzen nicht gerade
billig aber bequem
vor allem wichtig im Sommer wenn es
richtig heiß ist
sie sind gerne auf der Terrasse also
sorgen wir ab und zu dafür dass sie
gewaschen werden die Ohren gesäubert und
die Krallen geschnitten werden einfach
als Hygienemaßnahme
unterdessen muss Joey die zweite Katze
auf ihre Behandlung warten
[Musik]
gerade etwas überfordert mit zu vielen
fremden Menschen ich höre sie auch
miauen
jetzt fühle ich mich ein bisschen mies
dass ich sie rausgeholt habe
noch abduschen dann ist minilu gewappnet
wenn die Temperaturen wieder über 40
Grad steigen
so funktioniert hier alles man kann sich
Benzin nach Hause liefern lassen
Lebensmittel alles was man sich
vorstellen kann sogar eine Coiffeur der
nach Hause kommt um dir die Haare zu
schneiden es ist also ziemlich schwierig
in Dubai nicht faul zu werden
die Wüstenstadt ist nach dem
wirtschaftlichen Einbruch 2009 wieder
auf Wachstumskurs
bei Bauprojekten wird stets in
Superlativen gedacht davon kann sich
Michael selbst überzeugen auch der
urbane Event Golfplatz protzt mit
beeindruckenden Ausmaßen
[Musik]
aber natürlich
der Preis für das Spiel Vergnügen
variiert zwischen 30 und 60 Schweizer
Franken pro Stunde
Pornos für Michael hat den Dreh schnell
raus wer mit weniger Talent gesegnet ist
kann sich vom Nebenmann was abschauen
oder noch besser von der Nebenfrau
viele Stars und Künstler zieht es nach
Dubai die Dame ist eine DJ
sie nimmt sich sogar Zeit für eine
kleine Lektion mit Sophie
super ja man lernt einfach immer wieder
neue Lücken und
es rührt mich nicht aber dich lieb
Dubai gilt auch als Hotspot für Partys
ein Weg den der eher konservative
Nachbar Katar bei allen Reformen so wohl
nicht beschreiten möchte
Chris erwartet Gäste um sich in privaten
Rahmen wieder mal über die Situation in
Katar auszutauschen
eingeladen sind Rita und ihr Mann
der Hotelsektor ist für Rita ebenso
interessant wie der Stadionbau
schließlich geht es dort auch darum
langfristig gute Arbeitsbedingungen zu
schaffen knapp 900 Angestellte
beschäftigt Chris in seinem Hotel jetzt
fertig letzte Woche eine Gruppe
entdecken
erwartend das ist vor Screening die
kommentarlich und wenn er rekrutierst du
jetzt da
das ist ein damix über randoffice sehr
wichtig Gesicht vom Hotel sozusagen
alles andere kann ich trainieren
mein Schatz trainiert sind und verstehen
wird
so nah aus Aserbaidschan ich forme
und das sind jetzt aber Leute wo du wo
schon einmal schaffen
[Musik]
und da bin ich schon jetzt stolz drauf
also das ist das ist ein Erfolg von
Arbeit das Staat Katar jetzt das Kavala
System abbaut hat und es ist natürlich
klar und das ist immer das Clarke
bessere Arbeitsplätze
das ist natürlich ganz wichtige
gewerkschaftliche Forderung
Chris als gelernter Koch gibt sein
Bestes läuft alles gleich
ich koche übrigens
wenn ich koche darf er nicht in die
Küche weil er einem immer sagt wie man
es besser machen soll also darf er nicht
in die Küche
das internationale gewerkschaftsteam hat
heute mit der katarischen Regierung
darüber verhandelt wie man die
Verbesserungen auf den wm-baustellen
dauerhaft und vor allem für alle
Arbeiterinnen und Arbeiter in Katar
durchsetzen kann
das Abkommen unterschrieben mit dem
Arbeitsministerium wenn wir das
Abschaffen von kafala System oder das
funktioniert auch noch nicht überall
also die ganze Verbesserung sind noch
nicht überall implementiert und das ist
jetzt grosse Sorg also wir waren auch
nicht einfach jetzt sagen
und ich kann also wirklich sagen
die wissen dass nur vorwärts so und das
wird mir schweren Duschen wenn nach der
WM das wird die
Chris und Rita zwei die den
Strukturwandel in Katar in dieser
spannenden Zeit mitgestalten
in der nächsten Folge
Sonntagsausflug in die Wüste Andrea muss
ihren Jeep sicher durch die Dünen
steuern
außerdem hoher Besuch in der Schweizer
Botschaft Hotelier Chris trifft die
Schweizer fußball-prominenz
und
Solidarität für die migrationsarbeiter
der Einsatz von Gewerkschafterin Rita
trägt Früchte
[Applaus]